Willkommen an der Militärakademie in Wiener
Neustadt. Mein Name ist Oberst Markus Reisner,
ich bin der Leiter der Forschungs und
Entwicklungsabteilung. Und heute wollen
wir die Frage beantworten warum der Einsatz
der russischen Bataillonstaktischengruppen
der 2014 in der Ukraine erfolgreich angewandt
worden ist dieses Mal offensichtlich nicht
funktioniert hat. Das wollten wir anhand eines
einfachen Beispiels durchführen. Dazu entführe
ich sie mit dem März in den Raum nordostwärts
von Kiew und zwar in den Raum von Provari. Hier
auf dieser Karte können wir erkennen den Ansatz
der 90. Panzerdivision russischer Seite mit dem
sechsten Garde-Panzerregiment. Und dieser
Ansatz des sechsten Garde-Panzerregiments
in der Stärke einer Bataillonstaktischengruppe
(BTG) wurde erfolgreich von den ukrainischen
Kräften im Raum Provari abgewehrt. Und wie das
vor sich gegangen ist das werden wir uns jetzt
ansehen. Kurz noch ein paar Worte zur Gliederung.
In einem Video haben wir bereits dargestellt die
optimale Gliederung einer BTG was man bereits
erkennen kann in der Ukraine ist, dass die
russische Seite nicht immer über alle Kapazitäten
verfügt die normalerweise in dieser Normgliederung
vorhanden wären. Ich gebe hier ein Beispiel: den
TOS 1 zum Beispiel in unserem Fall wissen wir,
dass nur ein einzelnes oder ein zweites Fahrzeug
vorhanden waren und nicht eine ganze Batterie an
TOS 1, wie hier in diesen optimalen Beispiel
dargestellt. Das interessante ist auch,
dass 2014 beim Einmarsch der russischen Kräfte
in den Separatisten-Gebieten die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte das Problem hatten, dass sie
versucht haben sie in Grenznähe abzuwehren
und dabei von den russischen Kräften umfasst
worden sind bzw massiv mit Artillerie bewirkt
worden sind. Daraus haben die ukrainischen
Kräfte gelernt und sie haben diesmal die
russischen Kräfte herein gelassen und sich
dann erst später bekämpft. Auf der anderen
Seite haben die Russen versucht gerade mit
dieser Gliederung schmal, tief und schnell
vorzustoßen die Städte links und rechts
liegen zu lassen um rasch Drehscheiben
oder wichtige Geländepunkte einzunehmen und das
Problem war, dass sie damit konfrontiert waren,
dass sind dann in der Tiefe vor allem die
versorgungsrouten angegriffen worden sind.
Wie nun diese Verzögerung kam, von russischer und
ukrainischer Seite sich dargestellt hat, das sehen
wir jetzt anhand dieses Beispiels von Povari. Ich
habe das noch mal hier kurz ins Gelände gelegt,
wir haben hier Zentral den Raum Povari bzw die
Straße quasi die Richtung Nordosten führt. Die
russische Seite ist mit der BTG schmal und tief,
mit einer Geschwindigkeit von circa 25 bis 30 km/h
aus dem Raum Nordosten anmarschiert. Der erste
Hinterhalt durch leichte Panzerwaffen ist in
diesem Raum passiert. Die Kräfte haben auf diesen
Hinterhalt reagiert, wir werden es dann kurz sehen
und sind weiter angetreten. Was dazu geführt
hat, dass es noch einen weiteren Hinterhalt,
diesmal in Form eines Verzögerungskampfes durch
ukrainische Kampfpanzer gegeben hat und ein
Artillerieschlag, der schlussendlich dazu geführt
hat, dass die BTG aus der Organisation heraus
gerissen war und kehrt gemacht hat und versucht
hat an anderer Stelle noch einmal anzutreten.
Beginnen wir mit dem ersten Hinterhalt hier kann
man erkennen wie diese Situation war. Wir sehen
also die russischen Kräfte marschieren
mit relativ hoher Geschwindigkeit heran,
ohne Infanterie-Unterstützung und werden hier
flankierend durch den Einsatz von britischen
NLAW (NextGeneration Light Anti-Tank Weapon) und
RPG (Rocket Propelled Grenade) angeschossen. Man
erkennt zwei Abschüsse. Einer dieser Abschüsse
von dem System NLAW trifft diesen T-72 schwer.
Es führt dazu dass die Besatzung absitzt und
der Kraftfahrer versucht das Fahrzeug weiter
voranzutreiben. Der Rest der Kolonne versucht
auf diesen Hinterhalt zu reagieren. Das erkennen
wir hier. Einerseits kommt es zum Ausweichen
von Fahrzeugen in Richtung Osten, gepaart mit
dem Feuer der Maschinenkanone in Richtung der
vermuteten Hinterhaltstelle. Wir sehen das hier
an diesen beiden MT-LB bzw. BMP (Schützenpanzern).
Wir erkennen aber auch hier bereits das Eindrehen
der russischen Kampfpanzer mit dem Versuch
diese Hinterhaltstelle zu bekämpfen. Das sehen
wir hier das heißt die beiden T-72, die in der
Kolonne etwas weiter hinten geführt worden sind,
drehen ein und versuchen mit ihren Granaten
diesen Bereich wo also die ukrainische Seite
versucht hat quasi den Hinterhalt heraus zu führen
entsprechend anzugreifen. Dieser erste Hinterhalt
führt zu Verzögerungen und die russische Kolonne
tritt weiter an in Richtung Südwesten. Auf dem
Marsch entlang der Straße treffen sie auf
zwei ukrainische Kampfpanzer vom Typ T-64.
Diese beiden Kampfpanzer haben den Auftrag
einen Verzögerungskampf zu führen. Das heißt
sie beginnen die Spitzen der russischen seite
anzuschießen, wobei es ebenfalls zu Ausfällen
kommt am T-72. Dieser wiederholte Widerstand
führt dazu, dass die Kolonne der BTG sich zu
reorganisieren beginnt. Das heißt man versucht
den Raum zu verlassen weil offensichtlich auf
Seite der russischen Kräfte beurteilt worden ist,
dass es hier kein Durchkommen gibt. Wir sehen also
hier eine massive Zusammenballung der Kräfte und
wir wissen auch dass bereits zu diesem Zeitpunkt
vermutlich der Regimentskommandant also der
Kommandant der BTG gefallen ist entweder bereits
vorher durch einen Abschluss oder Panzer oder
Infolge des nun folgenden Artilleriefeuers von
ukrainischer Seite auf diese Zusammenballung
der Kräfte. Wir können also hier Elemente
einer BMP-Kompanie erkennen hier Teile einer T-72
Kompanie, hier Elemente der BTR 82 Kompanie, hier
den einzelnen TOS 1 "Burattino" und zusätzliche
Elemente die offensichtlich gerade im Feuer der
Artillerie liegen. Dieses artilleriefeuer setzt
sich noch fort, wir erkennen das hier an einem
weiteren Treffer in diesem Fall auf einem BTR-82.
Wir sehen auch hier sehr gut die Zusammenballung
der Kräfte und den beginnenden Abmarsch Richtung
Nordosten. Was man also hier erkennen kann ist,
dass die BTG den Angriff nicht weiter fortsetzt,
sondern Richtung Norden bzw. Nordosten ausfliesst
und sich dort vermutlich in einer Reorganisation
neu organisiert. Interessant ist, dass wir den
Funkverkehr des Regiments nach oben kennen
und wenn man sich den Funkverkehr ansieht,
sieht man das Chaos, das hier geherrschthat. Aus diesen wiederholten Angriffen es war
sogar so konfus, dass man gedacht hat von
russischer Seite, dass man auch mit Drohnen
vom Typ Bayraktar angegriffen wird. Wenn wir uns
das Ergebnis des Angriffes ansehen so sehen wir,
dass zumindest zwei T-72 B3 zerstört worden
sind 1 BTR 82A durch einen Artillerietreffer
hier vermutlich ein T-72 B3 in Besitz genommen,
dieser hier, aber auch zumindest zwei MT-LB wo
wir auf dieser Slide eines erkennen. Interessant
ist auch die Markierung, nämlich für das sechste
Garde-Panzerregiment, die Raute mit der Sechs im
Kern. Das Interessante ist, dass die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte ihre Erfolge vor allem darauf
zurückführen konnten, dass sie sehr gezielt durch
Drohnen die anmarschierenden russischen Kräfte
aufgeklärt haben und dann Präzisionsmunition
eingesetzt haben. Präzisionsmunition wie diese
Kvitnyk, ein Produkt das die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte selbst herstellen. Betrachtet
man die ausgefallenen russischen Panzer,
so kann man erkennen, dass viele einem massiven
Treffer erhalten haben, auf dem Top Bereich, der
wahrscheinlich zurückzuführen ist auf den Einsatz
einer derartigen Präzisions-Artillerie-Granate.
Zusätzlich für den Misserfolg der russischen
Streitkräfte und den Erfolg der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte ist sicherlich der bereits von
mir erwähnte Ausfall des BTG Kommandanten,
des Regimentskommandanten zu sehen, der hier
in den ersten Minuten des Angriffes oder zu
einem späteren Zeitpunkt durch Artillerie
gefallen ist, was dazu geführt hat dass
die BTG nicht nur die Hinterhalte zu ertragen
hatte sondern auch führungslos geworden ist.
Damit bin ich am Ende des Vortrages ich
danke fürs Zuhören und auf Wiedersehen.